hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
[Applause]
[Music]
April 10th
2023. what's going on how are ya
ah jeez April 10th two more months
before old freckles turns 55 Double
Nickel
coming around the clubhouse term down
the [__] back stretch here
I'm turning the corner
um
whatever what are you gonna do
what am I gonna do I don't know cry
silently at night where did all the time
go
um I learned a long time ago not to do
that
um you can spend your life wishing you
were 10 years younger or you could just
enjoy the age you're at knowing in 10
years you'd be happy to be where you're
at right like someday I'll be 65 and
I'll be looking oh my God 55 that sounds
so much younger
right
like 45 I'd love to be 45.
you know you're 35 you want to be 25
but when you're 45 you want to be 35 so
shut the [__] up
get out there enjoy yourself wow I've
been enjoying myself a little bit too
much lately
um as you know slash I preach every
month I take the first 10 days off every
month from everything
no sick guys no coffee no candy none of
that [__] well I was on the road in New
York and I met some buddies of mine
um one person in particular who I've
been like dude we gotta hook up we gotta
hang and he's always working so he's
finally was not working and he goes I
know the place God has the best coffee
in New York
all right I'm four days in to the 10
days off from coffee what am I gonna say
no
I'm in New York City right arguably the
Paris
of North America what am I going to say
I'm going to say no so I said [__] it I
went over there and you know if I try a
new coffee place
I have to get a double espresso and the
cappuccino
to see how they make both I did that
they were delicious
and then I said to myself and that's it
I'm just gonna shut it off again
but I was in New York
all these
great coffee shops and I'm like I never
get back here I miss being back here you
know
I could just go buy a newspaper you know
my old man [__] that I love doing just
buying a newspaper minding my own
[__] business sitting down
you know
looking like Clint Howard's cousin right
I just [__] I love doing that
although that let I find less and less
of the paper I can read
you know to try to blow through all of
the politics like when I got there
um
oh Donny boy
the D.A the D.A is calling for you that
whole partisan politic thing that they
did to him which is gonna just blow up
in liberals faces one of the stupidest
[__] things
you let a sleeping orange dog lie and he
didn't he did they did not they went
after this guy So eventually I imagine
there's going to be Republican D.A guy
and he's going to go after [__] uh
Joe Biden in all of his [__] life so
whatever so that's [__] so I skipped
through all of that
I can't read that noise you know it's so
stupid like the post is like oh my god
what the [__] and then the Daily News is
like yes yes
and then the New York Times it's like oh
that's basically their takes on politics
unless
it's something happening to a liberal
and then then the post will be like yes
yes
so I skip I skip all of that
um
and then then you're basically into page
six in local crime
you know so I keep the local crime light
if it's something [__] awful with a
woman or a kid or some [__]
you know I try to keep it light you know
I don't mind a little Smash and grab you
know
somebody you know steal somebody's cat
because they the relationship broke up
like I mean I I don't mind that
you know little bank robbery here or
there
little [__] car chase you know
someone jumps on a scooter like Tom
Cruise in that
that mission impossible going around
Paris
on a motorcycle how [__] great is
that guy's life
you know
does his own stunts he gets to ride like
a [__] Ducati or something at top
speed
through the shutdown streets of Paris
that was one of his days
hey Tom what are you doing today oh I'm
riding a Ducati through shut down
streets in Paris
while making 20 million dollars to see
to make a movie that's going to make a
billion dollars oh by the way I've been
doing this for 40 years
um
all right I'm a little envious
uh Slash scared to ride a motorcycle
unless the city is shut down even then I
don't think I'd get out of second gear
um
anyway so yeah and then I smoked you
know once with my buddy Doug and once my
with my buddy verzie
and uh as I mentioned but I haven't
smoked any more cigars
any but I've continued to drink coffee
now let's examine that why is that
because coffee is way easier to get
and I get home to my house and just like
I predicted
I wanted a cigar
I wanted a cigar so [__] bad the last
three nights but I I got rid of all the
cigars in my house and I knew this would
happen
I would want it but not enough to go out
and get it that's where I am when it
comes to addiction I feel the Cravings I
want it it makes me ornery but I don't
have that [__] thing to just throw a
jacket on and just walk out the house
in whatever wet weather and score
whatever the [__] it is I'm like a lazy
addict like if it's in the house
then I'll do it but if it isn't then I
don't do it and as long as I don't do it
for a little while it goes away
I know I'm boring you guys with this
[__] but I've been back on the coffee
pretty goddamn good
um today all I had was a double espresso
just kind of leave it at that possibly
in case my buddy calls later and then
maybe it goes to the next level I've
been continuing to work out
um
but I had a little setback with my
shoulder as always so I've been looking
up this [__] you know
the ice baths everybody's talking about
the ice bats and all of this type of
[__] and you know you go down
the rabbit hole next thing you know
you're online looking at the top of the
line ice bath which is just basically a
giant stupid [__] tub
and they're like well you know it weighs
about 40 pounds when it's empty so it's
easily maneuverable and put on its stand
once it's full it weighs 700 pounds
and I'm just thinking to myself
I I'm not that's a [__] plastic
container there's no [__] way that
that should be worth thirteen hundred
[__] dollars and then I'm gonna have
this thing and I'm gonna be really into
it for about maybe I don't know a week
or two or a month and then I'm just
gonna have seven I'm gonna have 700
[__] pounds of water sitting in my
goddamn garage
turning all different sorts of colors
and all of that [__] so I was like [__]
this
I'm not doing that what am I gonna I'm
gonna buy an ice bath what do you do
next buy a boat you [__] [__] you
don't do [__] like that in life people
you get to know people that own this
[__]
find a friend you gotta go hot chick
right
hot chicks get hungry just like
everybody else but they don't want to
pay for meals so what do they do they
act like they like a guy with a nice
watch and next thing you know they're
out there with the girls sort of hanging
out of a loose fitting [__] shirt
they're eating like a goddamn Pig right
the date ends with a little hug air kiss
and a little pet pat on the back go [__]
yourself two pets one freeze blue ball
go [__] yourself I just ate you gotta go
hot chick on the ice bath
do not
ask not I don't know why I'm in this
Kennedy mood here do not [__] uh
don't buy one of those [__] things
so then I did the next thing I was like
all right it's [__] la
it's Hollywood you know this is the
latest [__] craze
you know what I mean I kept my Botox I
have my enema [__] flush up my
[__] and then I go into an ice bath
and then at lunch I like to have soup
that's one of my favorite things ever is
when celebrities break down their day
for me like I was sitting around all day
going you know I wonder what Lewis
gusset Jr does what what time does Louis
Goss at you how does he shave his head
you know how does an oscar-nominated
actor shave his head
and what if I shaved what if I bought
the same shaving equipment Louis Gossett
Jr had what would would I then be happy
would I then be going up there accepting
the thing
that everybody wants
um
yeah so I looked at the next best thing
which is a place that has a [__] ice
bath
right and I'm sitting there going like
all right
so I go over there this is better now I
don't have to buy the thing I can just
go over and use the thing but then
you're getting into the the [__]
gross Factor
you know what I mean like who here is it
who here like you guys are here you ever
take a [__] yoga class
I mean you want to talk about taking
your life in your hands when you walk
into that [__] studio right after
another class and they have not mopped
up or anything
and it's that hot yoga it's like you're
in the [__] jungles of Vietnam right
and you can catch malaria through your
bare feet in one of those [__]
classes right
you just come walking in
if you're like me with your northern
European blood and you walk into this
tropical forest
where they've removed all foliage and
it's just the sweat and the emaciated
people I [__] uh I can't deal with it
like
there's no way to get like
I don't know I guess you uh yeah but
then you [__] put your mat down but
then your mat is ABS and it's like
rubber so it's like absorbing
how many [__] hours how many classes
of [__] plant-based Burger sweat you
know that's done God knows what I I
don't do so I you know I stopped going
to those things
so I started thinking about that ice
bath thing it's like all right this is
700 pounds of [__] water that's a lot
of [__] water
that's a lot of weight
and we always have a drought out here
how often are they changing that water
you know
I mean am I gonna get in that thing
right after Lou Diamond Phillips I I
don't think I am I don't know why I'm
just naming celebrities with three names
you know the other night I had a I had a
cigar with Ephraim Zimbalist Jr
um
so then I was like all right
because my shoulder's like really
talking to me man it's feeling inflamed
so uh
I finally was like wait a minute I have
a bathtub
I have ice I could fill the bathtub I'm
gonna
what the [__] is wrong with I have this
solution so I filled the bathtub up
I didn't have to make it [__] weigh
700 pounds or whatever was just a bath
and instead of hot water I just sat in
cold water I didn't do the ice yet
and I gotta tell you man I [__] loved
it it sucked getting in but I knew I put
my leg in and I went
and I was like [__] it get in again
I got the other leg in
ha all right and then I just said [__]
it I just sat down right up to my
gingered nipples and that's as far as I
could go and I was just going
oh just doing that right there's not
even any ice in it
so I'm working my way up to being
comfortable with it and uh but I feel
like you know
20 seconds I was fine and then I was
automatically immediately regretting why
didn't I go all the way up to my neck I
got to do this again and then I slid
down up to my neck and I was uh but then
you just sit there and you don't [__]
move
and I stayed in there for 10 minutes
and I really enjoyed it and uh
so I was in the bathroom you know
obviously of our bedroom
so I say
Tania I go Nia
I go come on in here she comes in I go
look this is ice cold water I go feel
the coldest water is I've been in here
for eight minutes and she's just looking
at me I go feel how cold it is she just
goes I can see how cold it is
it's made a [__] dick joke
when I was suffering
supper no I actually uh laughed my
frozen balls off for like [__] the
final two minutes and she was cracking
up I love making her laugh it's my
favorite thing in the way and she was
actually she was laughing because I was
laughing
uh she's the best and we were actually
talking about how we haven't done a
staycation in a while my favorite thing
to do and I think we're gonna go out to
the uh the dessert
I will never call it the desert I will
always call it the dessert in honor of
Greg Giraldo
your balls are sticking to your leg out
here in the desert
um
yes I'm thinking of going out there
maybe maybe in May but I I wrote a
little something that I'm directing in
May I'm very excited about so I have a
little pre-production
and then I'm in production and then
there's post but uh it's just gonna be a
quick little quick little four-day shoot
thing that I'm very excited about Oh
Billy Oh Billy director
you know
I'm gonna get myself a big stupid hat
one of those things to yell through
um
but anyway let's talk a little bit of
sports here shall we
um
by the way I'm still buzzing off of that
uh
hold on I'll put up my password here I'm
still buzzing off that uh Yusef days
experience band if you get a chance go
see them on tour
um [__] incredible
um all right let's talk a little bit
of sports here my dumbass who hasn't
watched one second of the Red Sox yet I
I was able to check in yesterday while
my kids were eating
checking out my uh basically my previous
relationship I had before my kids all my
sports packages so I checked out I do
have the baseball package I taped the
Tigers game today I'm taping this on the
ninth I know we won we scored 14 runs
the night before and evidently Chris
Sale is back
and he looks great
um which is very exciting
I mean
if you have an ace I mean he just limits
you know like an eight game slide
because he's going to be starting and
what do they start every five games or
something like that they can really just
you know
prevent any you know and I guess unless
the other three four guys absolutely
suck whatever I was excited to hear that
he's back
uh I think Devers had two home runs this
is the Saturday game I'm taping the one
today
uh the Bruins I watched the whole Devils
game
um they tied the modern record of 62
wins with the win over the devils and
it's funny people are like trying to
give like put the pressure on the Bruins
like oh it doesn't mean anything
if uh you don't win the cup and it's
like you know the pressure's on to win
the cup it's like what are you talking
about
the [__] Red Wings had 62 wins and so
did the uh the lightning and I don't
think either one of them won it
they want it in uh in 1819 they they won
62 games
right
wasn't that the year the Bruins lost to
the Blues in the finals as far as I know
so
it sort of goes with the territory that
if you win 62 or more games you don't
win the cup so they should be playing
loose
come the playoffs uh playoffs they
played the flyers today at 3 P.M
which I think just started I'm recording
that and they're going to be going for
the regular season record which is
pretty [__] cool
the uh the Masters
last I checked it was pouring down
raining I've been taping that and every
time I cut to it they're just showing
[__] rain coming down the golf course
so hopefully they got a sunny day uh
very happy that me and all my friends
and the dads everybody went last year
even though it was [__] as cold as a
football game on the Saturday last year
but the Sunday was absolutely gorgeous
uh
um I'm gonna be watching that this week
but uh I mean that's just one of the
great events every year you got you got
to watch the Masters you got you know as
a white guy
it's kind of hacky but you know
you gotta watch the Masters kidding
um but I do enjoy it it does draw me in
um
and then last but not least I finally
watched that April 1st race of Moto GP
in Argentina
uh
uh congratulations to Marco buseki I
hope I said it right he won uh he won
there at MotoGP two five years ago and
he repeated it in the rain
it was actually uh
a pretty exciting race as far as for
second and third
uh Francesco penae I'm probably saying
all these names wrong
worked his way up past Alex Marquez like
that was like the best racing and
everything that uh Johan zarko was doing
moving up uh from the back of the pack
was amazing he came all the way up to
second place but uh
Francesco banyani unfortunately was
going into a turn and I don't know how
they don't wipe out every time how low
they go but he ended up laying the bike
down and uh
I mean that put him in second place I
think he has uh I think he's down nine
points
to poseki but we'll see Mark Marquez
still watched it from home
still has that broken bone in his hand I
just wish that guy would come back fully
healthy
because he was already starting to look
like himself again riding like really
aggressive
and uh oh and also congratulations to
Valentino Rossi his first Moto GP P
first MotoGP win as an owner
um and I'm totally back into this sport
um I will be pronouncing the names
better as the season goes along I took
all the last year off I was so busy but
uh next week all freckles and
um and Dean Del Rey will be going to the
Moto GP race in Austin Texas cannot
[__] wait
um
and I'm doing some gigs in Texas and
then working my way over there on Sunday
it's going to be [__] awesome uh uh I
can't believe it I really can't believe
it I really wished I went years ago
because my favorite rivalry was uh
divisioso versus Mark Marquez and uh I
also kind of wish like um Ducati still
had that red you know
they got that lighter blue almost like a
Porsche blue
um which is interesting so I'm really
trying to like learn the names and the
numbers and all of that so when they
come zip it by like I'm gonna be able to
see it I just can't believe I'm gonna go
to it
um
very very very excited about that so
with that I think it's time to do a
little bit of advertising reads here did
I talk about everything I want to focus
talk about
I think so oh my son knows how to Pedal
now
you got this little fire engine from his
uh his grandmother for Christmas
and um
yeah he knows how to Pedal now which is
[__] amazing
um
it just took him forever he would just
kind of go forward and back forward and
back and now he finally got it down
so I brought the fire engine out of the
house and out into the driveway
and uh he was paddling around still goes
back to his Fred Flintstone muscle
memory
but um and he's still big on the big
wheel he likes to go you know there's a
little Hill in the driveway he likes to
go down the [__] Hill it scares the
[__] out of me but um
I mean that's what boys do
you know your daughter fascinates you
where you just like is she more mature
than I am already at six you know and
then your son his job is just to scare
the [__] out of you
just constantly you know
his upper body strength is is ridiculous
he just goes around now and he just
walks up to like the uh
you know
what do you call it the counter in the
kitchen
he just grabs onto it pulls himself up
brings his knees up and just hangs there
and then he just looks over at me
it just stares gives me a cold stare
and then sets himself down
and then looks at me and then just gives
me the thumbs up and turns around and
walks away that's like his thing man
uh but anyway he's uh he's like all like
a big boy now
he's I'm very proud of him he's almost
potty trained no more passy none of that
type of stuff uh
he still loves trucks
um I took him and my daughter for a
little
Easter ride in my old Ford truck
and uh we had a great time my old Ford
truck which is not leaking at all
anywhere
because of that genius mechanic right
down the street and um
I actually every time I go into my
garage now I look under the truck and
break into an ear to ear grin I've owned
that truck
for almost 12 years and it's been
leaking something the entire [__]
time you know and I'm one of those uh
clean garage guys
you know like I believe
cars and trucks belong in a garage
where everybody else puts all their ex
used to this like storage
or they turn it into like some sort of
you know well I mean mine's half a
podcast Studio but what are you gonna do
here
um they turn into like a giant office so
like a gym or something
which is that's not even bad I don't
mind that [__] either I just hate when
you know
you see a neighbor and he lifts up the
garage door and all you just see is just
boxes and just [__]
some [__] Fisher-Price basketball
hoop
you know from 20 years ago his kids are
in his their 30s and it's just like I
don't want to be that [__] guy so
um
I'm one of those dudes like I sweep it
then I shop vac it and then I I wash the
floor
on like my hands and knees I just get it
sparkling like I want to be able to like
eat off in there like you know whenever
you know what it is because whenever you
see like these car shows these car
collectors
and you go in their garages you know
that they fixed it up
they fixed it up for the shoot but still
it inspires you like a refrigerator
the contents of a refrigerator back in
the day on MTV Cribs remember that they
would open it up and you'd be like look
at that look at how organized it is and
look at all those drinks and they're
just
you know and they always were just
stalked
it wasn't like uh you know you could
help you could hold eight cans of Coke
in a row and there was only you know
four there because you drink Coke there
would always be eight
and eight Fiji bottles of water and
eight things of iced tea and it just
[__] lined up
you know
like the Nazis at Zeppelin Stadium
foreign
this regimen
um
yeah anyway so like I get more inspired
by uh the [__] uh people's garages
and that type of [__] so
um that's what I'm doing after this
I'm cleaning up my little drum room and
then I'm cleaning up the garage
and that's it everything's just sort of
wedged in there
my drum room slash podcast Studio
um
slash whatever so anyway that's what's
going on with me
um
let's do a little bit of uh let's do
some reads here dude
um oh it's fume everybody
all right be smart don't start kick the
habit put it out before it puts you up
all phrases we've heard a hundred times
yet we still continue to have bad habits
now Jesus preaching to the choir here
our sponsor fume
spelled f u with the umlat
the double dots above the u m fume is on
a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us uh fume is a
naturally diffusive device that uses
plants and Behavioral Science to help
you trade out your negative habit for a
positive one fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemical chemicals like a vape by the
way
how awful do all those legal weed stores
look when you when you look I mean it's
amazing that it's that it's legal but
when you look in them
this it looks it's like a combination it
looks like a fast food place or like one
of those places you can buy like uh
comic books
uh definitely does not look healthy does
not look uh like they're just selling
the plant in there
um I feel like there's a lot of uh
I'm gonna go on a limb here I'm gonna
say that they're they're really
tampering with that stuff
um having said that I'm not going to lie
to you uh
somebody gave me a joint one time and it
was just like three Puffs and I was
I was done
and uh I was thinking like yeah that's
my kind of
thing you know what I mean like drinking
you just got to keep work oh wait I'm
actually talking about smoking in a
positive way let's get back to fume
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a vape fume uses
korres c-o-r-e-s and that's capitalized
too
cores korres infused with plants like
peppermint and cinnamon for delicious
flavors
fumes new version 2 model is is Snappy
and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap your fingers will
always
have something to do
I guess that's because uh you got a bad
habit huh you got restless finger
syndrome okay the easiest way to stop a
bad habit is to switch to a positive one
and really I think it's a little harder
than that
[__] heroin I'm gonna start reading
books to my child
sitting there [__] sweating uh the
easiest way to stop a bad habit is to
switch to a positive one fume is
designed perfectly to do just that oh
because it also kind of feels like
you're doing something bad but you're
really not it's fume's goal to make
switching easy and even enjoyable God
bless these people they have thousands
of five star reviews from people just
like you
who successfully switched when other
Solutions just didn't work head to
tri-fume
t-r-y-fum.com and use code Burr to save
10 off when you get
the journey pack today
Oh Sherry uh the journey pack comes from
with was that his solo stuff
um Journey pack comes with three unique
flavors and the new version two fume to
help kick start your positive habit
that's try fume
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Burr
b-u-r-r to save an additional 10 off
your order today
oh look who it is people liquid death
I like these guys so much I invested in
the company I'm not quite that Norelco
razor guy Victor kayem I didn't buy the
company
all right I know that kind of scratch I
mean what do I know about the bottle can
water bottled water no canned water
business there we go uh liquid death by
now you've probably seen liquid death or
maybe you've heard me talk about their
Mountain Water and flavored Sparkling
Waters that look just like tall boys now
they have this new line of iced tea that
I love I'm not gonna lie to you I tried
it and I did love it these cans of iced
tea are healthy unlike uh those other
Iced Teas that are loaded with sugar
these are lightly sweetened with six
grams of Premium Agave are only 30
calories and provide a micro dose of 30
grams of caffeine per tall boy they also
have enhanced they're also enhanced with
B vitamins there are three flavors of
iced tea so you know I like this [__]
it's just like you can make money
by not poisoning people right I don't
know why
how is poisoning people cheaper that
poison must be [__]
a yeah it's got to be they just got to
be giving it away right there are three
flavors of iced tea Grim leafer rest in
Peach an armless Palmer
that sounds like the first three punch
lines of my stand-up career
tell you it was a rough one okay uh
liquid dust new Iced Teas are available
now and with free shipping on Amazon and
retailers near you as an added bonus
Monday Morning podcast listeners get 20
off their first liquid death apparel
purchase available exclusively at
liquiddeath.com
exclusions May apply that's
oh by the way guess what I did the other
day that I have not done since 2015.
I went skating
well I played pickup hockey in September
2015 thinking that that was going to
continue and then I hurt my back and
then we got pregnant with my lovely
daughter and then that was it you know
when kids just make years fly by and
it's been Jesus Christ it's been almost
[__] eight years
and I went out there like Tim and Terry
when I got on the ice I was like on
should I wait it was like a public skate
but I was like should I [__] wear a
helmet
okay I don't need to be cracking my old
[__] egg here on the goddamn ice
but no one was wearing uh
a helmet you know except for little kids
and peer pressure got the better of me
so I left it in the car
um
and I went skating with my daughter and
we had such a great time and uh
a lot of muscle memory I mean I only
play pickup hockey from
2010 to 2015 I was like upon hockey
skater before that I stunk so I didn't
have a lot to lose but um
it was still there a little bit it
definitely made me want to play well my
kids get a little bit bigger uh
maybe uh I'll start doing the pickup
hockey again but we used to play it was
like 11 30 to 1 in the morning get this
[__] unbelievable sweat but then you
came home and you were just like [__]
wired
I'd be laying there till like three in
the morning like Wide Awake
um but it was still great we still like
once a week
um
I might get back to that man it was fun
definitely fun
it's one of those great old man Sports
where even if you're not going fast you
still feel like you can run because your
Jersey's still gonna flap in the breeze
a little bit right
oh Jesus Billy I look like a bald
Landing McDonald out there all right
um
oh here we go we got we got the Reeds
here for all the wonderful listeners
writing in
close range hi Bill uh thanks for the
shout out to Eddie peppertone last year
I didn't know him and have been loving
his latest album oh that guy's a [__]
genius
Eddie pepitone is a [__] beast he's
one of the best Comics out there
you know
and uh this business is how this
business is
you know
and Eddie just isn't you know the
ingenue he used to be so now he's got to
make it you know back in the day Eddie
made it on his looks now he has to do
the work
no I'm kidding Eddie is uh just he's a
Comics comic I will anytime I see him I
will stop I guess I gotta watch this guy
and uh I love watching him because
nothing he talks about is anything that
I would ever think about
he's just in his own lane and is just
awesome to watch so definitely check him
out if you get a chance Eddie
pepperdome all right on Thursday you
mentioned seeing at close range yes I
heard Sean Penn tell a great story about
Christopher Walken that I thought you
might enjoy oh that's that's okay
before we get into that I actually
watched a movie that I think was
Christopher Walken's first movie because
the credit said introducing
uh Christopher Walken it's called the
Anderson tapes
and it's directed by Sydney Lament
um who did everything from 12 Angry Men
to uh the verdict one of the great
directors of all time and uh the story
behind this this one the Anderson tape
it's it stars Sean Connery
and it's evidently the movie that helped
him break out of being Typecast of
playing James Bond so it was really a uh
significant movie it's a strange movie I
will tell you that there's definitely
some questions I don't quite unders
didn't quite get answered
um but
there's a lot of uh character actors in
there
um Conrad is it Bane the guy who played
Mr Drummond
on Different Strokes now the world don't
move to the B to just one drum what
might be right for you may not be right
for some
oh that some will never leave my head
um
that's the first time I saw oh I saw
Janet Jackson First on on uh Good Times
but uh on uh on Different Strokes yeah
that's when I I just went uh Macho Man
on Different Strokes yeah
that's the first time I've ever seen her
going God damn she's [__] gorgeous
[Laughter]
oh little baby
watching the show so anyways Conrad Bane
I think this is his name he is in that
movie too and last night I had this
[__] random dream I was at a party
and Conrad Bane even though he's dead
was at the party and he was sitting
there
look in the age he looked like when he
was in the Anderson tapes and I walked
up to him in the dream and in my head
going like that can't be the guy from
Different Strokes that guy's dead
and I walked up I said hey man how are
you and he said hey what's going on uh
because everybody talks like me in my in
my uh in my dreams what's going on how
are you and I say hey Conrad what do you
say there [__] doctor so
um
I said uh
hey I saw one of your first movies he's
like oh is that right I said yeah I saw
the Anderson tape and he just laughed
and goes I I wasn't in that and I was
like oh my God that wasn't
Conrad Bane obviously because he's dead
I wonder who that guy is that looked
just like him and that was the end of
the dream
but anyway Christopher Walken
is in the introducing Christopher Walken
is in that movie
um
all shot in New York all these great old
taxi cabs and police cabs and all uh
police caps police cars all that [__]
that I [__] love from back in the day
so anyway uh check that one I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie to you it's
weird has a weird soundtrack there's
some weird jumping forward and coming
back like Sydney lament I think was kind
of getting out of
he tells stories more in like a linear
way I felt up until that I think he was
trying to do like some different [__]
but it's still definitely a cool movie
watched it on YouTube
all right so anyways
at close range Christopher Walken's
story that Sean Penn told anyway uh
walking has an intense phobia of guns
welcome to the club I [__] love guns
and when I go into a gun store like I
look as I want to buy every [__]
thing in there especially if it looks
like any gun that I've seen in a movie I
just don't have any training and I
respect them so I'm like afraid that I'm
gonna do something you know I'm not
afraid to look but if I anytime I've
gone to like a gun range there's always
that thing like I don't know what the
[__] I'm doing just
keep your finger off the trigger unless
you're gonna pull it and don't have your
finger on the trigger unless you're
pointing out what the [__] you want to
shoot at and know what the [__] behind
it but we're at a gun range so that all
of that's okay but I always get worried
even like a gun range that there's gonna
be some guy you know the guy who sets up
like the paper
cutouts is just gonna come walking out
and I didn't hear the ceasefire you know
like some kid in an old school bowling
lane who's got to come out and set up
the [__] pins
um
but I do love it man but I love the
revolvers man the [__] like the the
old cop looking guns the Dirty Harry but
every everyone everyone that I know that
have a shot like a 44 magnum was like
dude after the first shot I didn't want
to shoot it anymore it like hurt my
[__] arm
um so if I ever went to a gun range and
shot one of those which I'm probably
gonna do just to [__] do it
um I'm only gonna put one bullet in
because I mean it's bad enough if it
came up and smashed me my big dumb head
but I just don't want to be that guy
where it flies out of my hand lands on
the ground and then [__] blows
somebody's leg off or whatever the hell
that gun could do I just don't want to
be that guy
um anyway bill can we get to [__]
Christopher walking you know instead of
you talking all right
um he has an intense phobia of guns to
feel safe he makes a habit of triple and
quadruple checking the dummy loads in
any guns that will be in a scene he's
performing in
wow how the [__] did he get through the
deer hunter knowing this Penn walked out
of view as the filming of the climactic
final scene began and says give me that
other gun
oh my God loud enough that walking would
hear came back into view and started
this scene the fear on Watkins face in
the movie looks very real because he's
really [__] terrified
oh my God Penn was only 17.
what
he had the balls to do that that's
[__] incredible
the fact that he knew how to elevate the
performance of a legend and had the
balls to do it is [__] amazing I
couldn't say it any better than you just
said it I love those [__] stories
those [__] still that's amazing
I would I I
would just be going just just make sure
you know your lines so Mr Walken doesn't
get mad
this guy's like I'm gonna [__] with him
um
now I have to go back and watch that
scene
um
anyway I've been big into like uh
I I don't recommend this to anybody like
if you grew up in like the 90s or
something like that if you're born in
the 90s go back watch a bunch of movies
from the 90s just to look at the cars
and all of that and all these cool
memories it's not even about the movie
like you'll hear a song
and it just puts me back in a station
wagon
you know
riding home from my dad's job because we
had like one car so we would all get in
the car drive my dad to work if my mom
needed the car and came home you know
and we would you know whatever like
Carly Simon all of that [__] just I'm
immediately back into this we had this
uh
Buick station wagon like navy blue
I want to say with black interior
and uh
it was I want to say it was like almost
like a mid-size did they make a
mid-sized station wagon back then I
can't remember
we were sort of like a Buick family
like before that we had like this 73
Buick Regal
that had like these [__] doors that
were like you know as thick as a safe
um
I don't know I love doing that [__] all
right liberal gun owner and former
Banker [__]
um all right hearing from the gun owners
I love it Guillermo Spanish for William
um
on your March 30th podcast you asked for
gun owners to write in with solutions to
curb mass shootings yeah who would know
better
via better regulations of purchasing of
a firearm Yeah just something that that
lets regular people get the guns they
want
and how do we prevent [__] idiots
from getting them doing horrible things
and then [__] it up for the law by
law-abiding gun owner
is basically that seems to be the
question right and this is what I'm
asking having no knowledge of guns or
legislation whatsoever so for some
reason we're going to bounce it off of
me
if this doesn't say you're listening to
a podcast right now I don't know what
does uh I am a former Banker [__]
who spent eight years working with
insurance benefits and a current gun
owner can you please write back in and
let me know why you stopped banking did
it get to you
could you not do it anymore or did you
find something else to do I don't know
this is relevant because I have some
credibility to to speak on this and in
my time there okay so what is
uh relevant here he's a former Banker
[__] eight years working with insurance
benefits and current Gunner okay
um I heard some experts familiar with
the industry Insurance specifically
propose a solution that I think would
actually have a solid chance of making a
meaningful difference
a solution could be to require gun
owners to carry insurance
this is going to stop a nut from doing
something crazy he's going to worry
about his pre is his [__] premium
going up
gee I'd really love to shoot up that
food court but God damn it my monthly
payment would go through the [__]
roof all right I'm gonna be open-minded
here now I know that
communist Ginger that communist Ginger
hair of yours is standing up on the back
of your neck
when did I become a commie
I'm doing great in capitalism
uh I just feel like this should be like
you know like uh like in um
like in baseball
some sort of luxury tax that's all a
revenue sharing is revenue sharing
communist
and if it is
then doesn't communism work within the
NFL
we just opened up all kinds of cans of
worms here
um
anyway uh now that down now I know that
a communist Ginger hair of yours is
standing up on the back of your neck
just reading that sentence but hear me
out and buckle up because this is going
to be a tad lengthy
all right well I didn't stand up because
of Any communist socialists or
I don't know capitalist thought I just
was like I don't think a crazy person
gives a [__] about insurance
or maybe they can't get I'll just shut
up you have to get insurance to own a
car right that is well yeah I mean in
theory
that doesn't stop people from drying
down the street without it
um and as long as you're not an [__]
it's really not that expensive and if
you are a good driver it is in fact is
very inexpensive it is also very easy to
get insurance with plenty of small and
large firms across the U.S you can also
get most policies that same day like
buying a car so that addresses the
concern of responsible gun owners not
being impeded to purchase and continue
owning a gun while also requiring
something that is not excessive anyone
that tells you that this is an undue
burden on your second amendment rights
is not a serious person see now why
couldn't you just say that without
insulting because now they're going to
get all [__] upset
um
now why why would it help
here are some things to consider no one
is better at assessing risks than
insurance companies
uh yeah but now now don't they have to
get into like psychological [__] uh
there is a huge incentive to ensure
companies are not ensuring anyone that
might be mentally unstable had domestic
violence issues or other behaviors slash
factors that might indicate they are
more likely to use lethal Force okay
such as payouts to victims families from
the perpetrators insurance policy no
parents should have to ever suffer the
financial burden of burying their child
uh okay the government is not involved
for all the [__] that think they won't
get droned by the Nerds
uh it would create jobs lots of gun
owners to ensure it adds a step that may
give any ill-intended time to rethink
their actions
and get help instead
I don't know about that
I think of you nutsy nuts it will ensure
maybe somebody who's just
pissed off
it will ensure at least some people who
should not have firearms do not get them
all right
yeah this does go on okay we got two
more long paragraphs bear with me
everybody now why do now why do we need
this oh I love when people ask the
question for me
now why do we need this I didn't ask
obviously this was prompted by shootings
but my own experience purchasing a
firearm is Case in point to keep it
brief several years ago my wife and I
moved from our home state of New Mexico
to a state where we did not know anyone
this is part of the reason I decided to
purchase a shotgun and a handgun at the
time we were living with friends as we
just sold our house and did not have a
permanent address when I went to buy the
gun I did not have the necessary
documents such as a bank statement with
the current address that matched my
documents I was almost not able to
purchase the guns but thankfully I had a
very helpful salesman we will call him
Frank now Frank knew that I didn't have
the necessary documents but he prided
himself in being a patriotic American
and wanted to help me out Frank told me
to go to the other end of the store
where they also sold fishing licenses
and asked to purchase a temporary
one-day fishing license and that would
be enough for me to walk out with both
guns
yeah well you can see the potential
problem there uh when I walked to the
other end of the store to purchase these
licenses a stout and Keen gentleman
assisted me in the purchase purchasing
this license it was about 4 P.M that day
and when I asked for the one day
efficient license he asked if I was sure
because of how late in the day it was
and the pass expired to 8 PM I told him
I was sure and that it was not an issue
he squinted slightly and asked if I was
sure again I assured him it was fine he
then proceeded to ask me sir are you
purchasing the license to obtain a
firearm today I'm not going to lie bill
I almost cracked but was able to muster
a solid nope
I like how the fishing guy is doing more
[__] than the guy actually selling the
gun
uh I'll get that done for you right away
he says okay I'll get that done for you
right away in under eight minutes I had
my one day fishing license and I was
back with freedom Frank himself
finishing up my background check and he
finally handed me my guns with a fire
firm handshake and a smile walked out a
proud gun owner that same day well at
least you're a good guy
um
all right so you're saying I I don't I
don't know if I'm smart enough for this
so you're saying if they get insurance
if you had to have insurance
um
you're saying the insurance companies
would do way more of a background check
than this fish
and game place that you went into
all right so they would do more than
that but you think that they and
evidently you think that they would do
enough that that wing nut down there in
Tennessee would not have been able to
get
a gun now couldn't that person been like
you know you're doing this because I'm
transitioning and then when they get
scared when their corporate lawyers get
scared of that
I don't know
all right well there's one solution
potential solution or a gun solution hey
Billy bullet time
they're gonna go with bullet head I've
got two small kids I'm a gun owner and
like you I've been trying to figure out
the solution to these school shootings
well I honestly dude I think so much of
it is if they wouldn't [__]
give these [__] that do it you know
more media coverage than the quarterback
that won the Super Bowl I think that it
would
you know stop the psycho monkey see
monkey do type of thing out there
um
I mean why am I getting into a [__]
ice bath who the [__] would ever get to
a bath with ice in it no one no one ever
until you see it and people go oh this
is good and then all right I'll do it
foreign
that's how psychos look at school
shootings where you look at it like it's
horrifying they're like oh that's what I
could do with my weekend
um all right anyway we can Implement
Nationwide uh gun laws background checks
waiting periods limited capacity
magazines and ban certain types of guns
like we've done here in California but
does that work it didn't work with that
72 year old Asian dude who shot up the
dance hall in Monterey Park he
circumvented all of those laws with a
banned gun similar to an Uzi with high
capacity magazines we can't rely on
armed guards or the police to handle
every situation that disaster in
Uvaldi taught us that so what do we do
we harness artificial intelligence
is that all we have to do
just harness artificial intelligence
like you're gonna say how to do that
video cameras and security doors we put
a comprehensive comprehensive system of
cameras in and around the schools we
hook them up to Ai and teach it to
recognize handguns and rifles as that
[__] hard with the gun approaches the
school AI spots it and puts the school
in lockdown if the gun is hidden the
minute it comes out of the bag inside or
outside of the school the school is put
into lockdown that's my solution thanks
and go [__] yourself
uh you and all Buck Rogers on it all
right well I'll do the whatever who's
gonna pay for that oh bulletproof
windows
um
I mean so you're basically you want to
go Terminator you want to have like
robots outside the school
you know when somebody approaches ah you
with Santa Connor are you a school
shooter they'll come over and just take
them out of me that would be that would
be ideal
but I mean I know how much my computer
[__] up what happens when the the
Terminator robot that's one thing that
is missing in The Terminator
is uh a a like a defect in The
Terminator he never seems to need to
reboot
he always seems to kill the people he
wants to kill
it's very odd
um one of the genius things of that is
when they brought Arnold back
and they're like yeah he's still playing
the Terminator but now he's a good
Terminator
I mean I want to say they ripped off
Hulk Hogan with like the you know
if he has the blonde mustache he's the
good guy if he adds the the black pine
tar beard then he's a bad guy
anyway everything goes back to
everything goes back to Blues jazz or
wrestling
a lot of people say Shakespeare I I I'm
giving Vince McMahon and those guys a
little more credit all right down 200
pounds what
what get the [__] out of here you lost
200 pounds
I'm sitting here trying to lose my
[__] 20 pounds of coveted weight
well good for you sir or ma'am or they
[Music]
um
Bill you're the first person who ever
made me feel gross for being fat
okay I'll take that as a compliment a
few a few years back I took your shaming
to the heart and lost 200 pounds
I put back on a hundred and fell off the
wagon hard ah [__] bill I can't keep
away from fried food anyway I'm backing
down I'm back down to a healthy weight
again and maintaining it shout out to
everyone actually trying to do anything
absolutely that's amazing I gotta tell
you the fact that you put 100 back on
and we're able to stop
um you have the willpower dude I believe
in you
and uh
you know what why don't you try the
thing that I'm failing at this month
which is taking the first 10 months off
10 months the first 10 days of every
month off I shut down everything
uh well I guess you you need to
permanently shut down those things
um
yeah I'm a stop dude because that's
that's a life-threatening thing that
you're dealing with and it's above my
pay grade I was going to be like why
don't you learn to play a musical
instrument
hahaha
every time you watch some buffalo wings
get it break out that ukulele
get some fume you know light one of
those [__] up see what happens
um I don't know hey I gotta tell you
something
um that little [__] I'd even do an
ice bath it was just cold water it has
affected my mood like I am in a uh I'm
in a better mood I'm in a sillier mood
I like to think a lighter move
um
letting [__] roll off my back that's how
I want to be it's how I want to live the
rest of my life here
um anyways that is the podcast uh
is there anything that I forgot as far
as Sports I know this is a crazy time
with sports with everything
everything's coming up
NBA NHL playoffs MotoGP I haven't been
watching Formula One
I'm sure it's great uh I'm just psyched
and thank you to everybody in College
Station that's coming out to the show
next week I cannot [__] wait
um
to go to that that uh Moto GP race this
is something it's been a long time
coming and um
I swear to God when I see those
motorcycles I hope Mark has this racing
next week
I mean I remember when I went to a
formula one event when I when I saw
like
um Lewis Hamilton's Mercedes back when
they had like the green and silver the
Silver Arrow there like like the car
alone was like seeing a celebrity
um
just one of those moments you know when
you just see something for a long time
and then all of a sudden you're there
you're like how the [__] am I at the
same place this [__] is happening
is still one of my goals though is I
want to go to Mexico City for that
formula one that goes through the old
baseball stadium I think that's the
coolest thing ever and I want to sit in
those [__] bleaches
and watch them all come through the
chicane
um all right that is it that is the
podcast uh go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on you
on Thursday and now I'm never ready to
shut it off and then we go